colin pitchfork could be a free man in
days
though he'll have to live under tough
restrictions
he's done 33 years in prison since he
raped and strangled school girls lynn
mann and
dawn ashworth but the parole board has
rejected
probably the last attempt to keep him
inside
concerns over pitchfork's freedom went
beyond the girls leicestershire
community
change is absolutely possible and i've
known offenders to change after doing
the most horrendous things
but for that change to be genuine they
need to
change the underlying values and the
underlying motivations that led them to
offend in the first place
and when we have somebody who is
essentially a misogynistic sex offender
that is a very difficult and lengthy
process for them to
undergo pitchfork's crimes were
notorious
in his case dna evidence was used for
the first time
lawyer simon crichton said the parole
board rarely got things wrong
isn't it possible that colin pitchfork
has hoodwinked the parole board into
releasing him
there's a very high bar for the pro
board to make a decision whether to
release somebody
and of course what we do know is that
the number of cases where
people reoffend after being released by
the pro board for serious convictions is
vanishingly small
so the problem do tend to get this right
most of the time
and what what would have to be
established is that they behaved
irrationally
in making that decision and clearly that
that threshold hasn't been met
the parole board said it had immense
sympathy for the victims families but it
had a legal duty to assess if and when
pitchfork was safe to be freed onto the
streets
dawn ashworth's mother barbara said she
was disappointed
but she'd lived with her daughter's loss
for many years and she said of pitchfork
he can't hurt me anymore pitchfork had
done more than his minimum sentence
he'd had parole rejected twice before
legitimate reasons for keeping him
locked up had run out
martin brunt sky news